mireille mathieu sur antennes veut tout
au long de la journée vous l'avez
constaté mireille mathieu est en effet
la marraine du téléthon qui le 2 et le 3
décembre prochain sera une nouvelle fois
sur notre chaîne l'événement télévisé de
l'année le téléthon sera consacrée cette
fois encore à la myopathie
mais aussi à d'autres maladies qui
frappent le nerf et le muscle jean
daniel flaysakier bernard ouf les ont
accompagnés mireille mathieu qui a rendu
visite à des enfants myopathes
quand des affections aux noms étranges
comme la dystrophie musculaire de
duchenne de boulogne ou encore la
maladie de vernis hoffman ou coup dans
un fauteuil
vous avez besoin de rêver besoin de
peindre des arcs en ciel pour oublier
qu'on ne pourra peut-être pas à les voir
de près à quoi ressemblent les aurores
boréales par exemple alors malgré tout
on garde le sourire comme olivier même
si l'on doit passer sa vie dans un
fauteuil même un fauteuil qui roule avec
un moteur et puis surtout si on doit
lire à travers des lunettes à prismes
comme le fait wolfgang on regarde quand
même la vie en face
un luxe qui varie pas eu de points
d'interrogation
qu'est ce que tu fais tu es aussi les
bons moments comme ce matin la visite de
mireille mathieu une visite qui lance le
téléthon 88 un téléthon qui donnera
encore plus de munitions à la recherche
pour combattre ces maladies barbares qui
inexorablement détruisent jour après
jour les nerfs et les muscles de ses
enfants qui ne demandent cependant aucun
vivre